[Musique]
protéger le panda est une des missions
du ZooParc de Beauval ici ce n'est pas
une les biens de naissance de Panda que
Beauval a eu l'immense honneur
d'accueillir
2017 première naissance première en
France en plus 2021 autre naissance et
en plus cette fois ce sont des jumelles
et qui est leurs parents qu'il y a
Mbappé c'est pas la classe ça
franchement
[Musique]
mais bon cela n'enlève rien au besoin de
conservation de cette espèce en danger à
Beauval ils l'ont bien compris et
mettent tout en œuvre pour préserver ce
petit ourson
[Musique]
donc là ils sont là derrière et toi tu
t'occupes spécifiquement dépenda ou tu
fais aussi d'autres on s'occupe des
autres animaux on a les koalas un peu
plus en bas on a aussi les ours les
loups et je vois que tu as ramené de
quoi manger c'est ça on a ramené un
petit peu de bambou donc pour donc c'est
le grand frère qui est qui est dans cet
enclos aujourd'hui
et ensuite on a une petite balle
badigeonner de miel donc je pense qu'il
va fortement apprécier et ensuite on a
une petite pochette avec des compléments
alimentaires dedans donc c'est des c'est
des granulés en fait on va essayer de
l'appeler et on va voir si il va venir
ça fonctionne tu vois c'est pas mal ils
aiment bien l'opéra
philosophe Goya
Pandi panda qui vient de l'Himalaya
indépendant petit tour de Chine
on te protège
super il y en a combien ici dans le parc
dans le parc actuellement on en a 5
ouais on a le papa à la maman le grand
frère donc Pascal
Pascal le grand frère un chinois et
ensuite du coup on a les deux bah les
jumelles donc les deux petites qui sont
nés déjà il y a un peu plus d'un an mais
alors mais comment tu es venu à ce
métier Fabien alors moi depuis deux
petits j'ai visité beaucoup avec mes
grands-parents le ZooParc de Beauval et
puis de fil en aiguille après je me suis
vraiment intéressé aux animaux il
réclame son petit cul
de miel
donc alors il mange quoi on a dit du
miel du bambou l'arme nutrition de base
c'est vraiment le bambou donc il sur 24
heures ils ont environ 60 kg un peu plus
de 60 des fois ça dépend pour certains
individus j'ai jamais vu un panda
d'aussi près Fabien merci c'est grâce à
toi c'est grâce aux eaux parcs de
Beauval c'est ça Beauval c'est la magie
quoi allez tiens tu l'auras bien mérité
merci beaucoup
les gens m'ont entendues
et en plus il fait ça bien